so listen there's a lot of people at the
woman especially that I mean that are
powerful but today we decided to do a
little different I said why don't we go
find the most powerful woman in India a
country of 1.2 1.3 billion people
according to Ford the Fortune magazine
she's the most powerful woman in India
and according to Forbes she's the top 25
most powerful woman in the world and
that is SBI's former chairman Arundhati
thank you so much for taking the time
and welcoming us into your place it's
been a wonderful experience being in
India and yesterday you and I were both
speaking at the IIT summit and we were
in the back talking and then a new
spokes came and I'm like listen I'm
trying to speak to this woman and I'm
trying to run from her and everybody's
distracting and so I'm glad we had the
time to get back together here today so
to put things up some things into
perspective you know your career has
been absolutely amazing
and in in India you're obviously
celebrated by a lot of different people
you took a bank that's been around since
1872 is just been on for a while and
recently before you leave in you had
five associate banks that I think came
together which made SBI now the fiftieth
largest bank in the world I think you
guys have two hundred and seventy eight
thousand employees I'm trying to see if
I'm getting the numbers right half a
billion customers right that's right
24,000 branches you have give or take
the numbers that I'm saying and you're
the chairman running this entire company
so before you became this person how did
the whole thing get started initially
for you I joined the bank a long time
back in fact I served it for $40 so now
you and I when you were talking
yesterday you were sharing with me that
you know I asked you guys so it's a very
common for a woman to be running backs
and some of the stories you were telling
was fascinating because you are the
first chairman of a fortune 500 company
that's based at Indy I think you
but but are there a lot other woman that
are running banks and major financial
firms here in India is this becoming a
very normal thing yes it has it has
because if you look at the largest
private sector bank that's also run by a
woman and she's been running it now for
the past seven years then the number
three private sector Bank is also run by
another woman at one point of time the
number two public sector bank also had a
woman as the leader in fact even foreign
banks in India a number of them are led
by women so whether it be Bank of
America Standard Chartered Morgan
Stanley HSBC at one point of time she's
also just retired so a large number of
foreign banks in India also have what is
I asked you this question and I'm gonna
ask it again
why do you think that it is their
reasoning is it the fact that you know
is it because culturally in India the
woman make the decision for money or it
just so happened that woman came up in
the leadership position don't think
culturally women make the decision where
money is concerned I think what happened
in 1969 the Indian government went in
for nationalization of banks and the
idea was that man's weren't really
expanding and spreading out towards the
villages and getting more and more
people in or providing more and more
banking services to people so the
mandate on nationalization was expansion
at a very fast pace and when that
happened you know a lot of jobs came in
to me and in those days they want too
many opportunities for jobs the private
sector wasn't as vibrant as it is edgy
and you made it to know people in order
to sort of you know get a job so that is
when I think you know a lot of women got
in because they felt that this was an
opportunity that you could avail of on
the basis of merit alone so you needed
nothing other than grants one out
exactly what you want that's right you
know but the fact remains that in India
this is something really strange but we
had calculated at one point of time when
I was German about 55% of banking assets
were being read by that's unbelievable I
mean that's because our bank alone is
23% you know what would be fascinating
this for Harvard to do a case study on
India because I think if they keep
talking about you know inequality and
you know all the gender equality offices
around the world this is not just an
American thing it's all over the world
this would be a very interesting case
study to see what happened in India that
caused where 55 percent of the money is
being controlled by a woman what was the
reason behind that but so I guess my
next question for you will be you talk
about the fact that you traveled a lot
and you're married your husband's also
career person is an ex professor of IIT
which part of which one is higher okay
so it is against better needs and you're
growing you're traveling you're having
to do all this stuff and you also have a
daughter you have a child as well was
there a point where in your career you
were going where you hit a marker where
you have to make a decision that was
extremely difficult within your personal
life and and if you did go through that
what decisions did you have to make how
did you process that to say because I
can't see somebody like yourself being
the most powerful woman in India and not
having that someone where you have to
make some very difficult decisions that
somebody may say you know what I'm just
gonna be a mom I'm just gonna say mom
did you go through that interview Dave
could you tell us about it as you
rightly said I think there is hardly a
woman who has a family who doesn't go
through that at some point of time yes I
did go through it and luckily probably I
had the right kind of support structure
to enable me to get past it for instance
when I got boosted to New York my child
is very very small
did Special K Lisbon they're very
luckily my aunt who had just retired and
she lives with us so she agreed to come
along with me to to New York to New York
okay to look after the check so that was
really a godsend and things worked very
well I left for New York alongside the
firm and for one and a half years things
were fine but then the immigration
attorney he told us that you know
probably you know you will not be able
to get another extension or visa she was
getting a six-month visa so she got two
extensions they said you know third time
in all probability she'll get refused
and if she can surf you she won't be
able to come back to the table so you
know it's better if she goes back for a
year and then for the remaining one and
a half years of your term we used to
have four-year terms
she can come back so this one year fine
if that's the way it should be done that
was okay with us but what happens to the
child and as you can imagine the child
at that point of time was spending much
of her time with my aunt so both my aunt
and my mother back in in India they sort
of insisted that it's only a matter of
one year she's still very young so you
sent her back to India for you okay and
obviously you know it's it's been one of
the toughest decisions my husband by
that time adjournment so he said he
would support my decision whatever but
it was mine to take okay so after a lot
of you know doing him flowing and trying
to understand the pros and cons and
talking to the doctors and the
counselors and everything ultimately I
decided to send him back to India but in
those days you know we had no spite no
faithful tile you do nothing and even
the phones were very unreliable we
didn't have mobile phones either so very
unreliable phone lines and in India
sometimes when you call you could hear a
ringing sound but actually speaking the
person on the other side would probably
have a dead phone so you know every
morning I would fall and every evening
I'd call and if I couldn't get through
one of
Dane's till I got through you know I was
an absolute little needles and I think
all my parents neighbors they also came
to know about it because you know if I
couldn't get two of my mother's lying I
would get two members to fight me too
but anyway luckily after the year was a
word that she did get your new love a
visa and she did come back let me ask
you when it comes down to that if you
were to speak to the woman out there the
ladies out there who our mothers or
they're running a business what could
you say to them when it comes down to
the processing on how to handle this
better because men are wired slightly
different than a woman how could you
what could you say to them so again I
think you know what happens is when you
continue to do your best in whichever
area you are in you are setting certain
examples okay because at the end of the
day you know if you are achieving
something it makes everybody around you
feel good and it's good to have people
really good at okay I don't think you
know that small things like whether
you're giving them their food or whether
you're you know standing beside them as
they didn't work I don't think these are
things that are so very important okay
and very often what happens is we get we
get sidetracked by certain rules that
society puts up for us
okay so for instance in Indian society
the woman of the household is expected
to eat after everybody else's it
this used to happen in our parents
generation now if you take that as a
rule then and you are not able to do it
very often you want to be before it
appear in a job like mine then you start
having all kinds of guilt feelings which
are absolutely useless
you know because why should you be bound
by you know rules that society makes for
young so I think you know overall I
don't really believe that you know
you're
changing anybody if you're doing a job
of course you know there are times when
you need to prioritize okay and that
prioritization has to happen for
instance somebody was sick at home you
need to practice very often people ask
me how do you do that because you know
they might be crisis in the office as
well sure and my short answer to that is
that you must have excellent teamwork an
excellent teamwork means that when the
leader or remember steps away the rest
can fill in the breach without missing a
beat so you know if you can get your
team to be like that then you can
continue to prioritize when you need to
travel I said there will be times I
really agree that you cannot always
prioritize office over there will be
times when when they needed and
similarly vice versa
but for both you know you need to have
those kinds of teams that can take up
the slack immediately and you won't feel
missed again I'll tell you why do people
not do that because many people are not
confident enough to make themselves
dispensable
many people are not confident enough to
make themselves dispensable yes you
always want to be indispensable because
you're not confident that even when you
are away Wow or even if you have media
so dispensable even then you will still
be valued that you would still be wanted
yeah that's a very very difficult about
it yeah and you're always trying to sort
of protect whatever you have so that you
know if you go away those others won't
be able to manage if you do that then
you're not going to be able to
prioritize one over that one thing
there's this traditional way of thinking
this is your way of thinking that
philosophies it's incredible so to two
questions for you with this because that
part was family right what things you
had to go through as a family now let's
talk about to become a chairman you have
to be a leader you're not just gonna
become a chairman without knowing how to
sit in boardrooms
manage ego deal with egos different
personalities you know leading men
leading women customer dishes political
issues diplomatic issues
all these different compliance issues
how do you one when leading the team
when a crisis happens what is your
immediate how are you processing a
crisis whether its leadership political
market whatever it is
how are you processing that as you're
leading your team as a leader if you
want to be effective you must be able to
get the bigger picture from as few data
points as possible so to the extent that
you know you should be able to see what
you are going to come up against okay if
you're not able to warn as vigilance
what is ahead of you and then you just
go and hit it there's a perfect that's
one thing the second thing I think you
know we have to understand is that you
must understand who's good at it and if
you have understood that and if you
understand the broader picture then it's
much easier to delegate the right pieces
to the right people now if you do that
what happens is if there is a crisis
then you can immediately call up that
particular team and have them sort of
start responding on in a very you know
anybody know what should I say in a
manner that is that is something which
they are capable of doing or I should
say you know that the speed of response
would be very good so you know again
very important to get the right people
in place in the right kinds of jobs very
important to be able to trust your team
so that you know you know that if you
tell them to get something done they
will get it done so how do you
understand that observing them see what
they wouldn't see what they're enjoying
doing I think some of these things do
working but at the end of the day it is
it is partly intuition as well
interesting in the last question this
will be the last question is India I was
invited to come to I
and initially we were not able to make
it work so finally we came back and
decided to come out and completely fall
in love just the culture the community
the way it is it's unbelievable India
now has a six largest youtube unit in
GDP in the world right you are the
largest democracy you are the second
largest english-speaking country in the
world outside America you are now like
the level of wanting to learn the hunger
factor with these younger entrepreneurs
coming up and you know you're having
young stories with people that all of a
sudden this guy becomes a billionaire
exactly you have a lot of good stories
right now in the other what do you
foresee taking place with the economy of
India in the opportunity of
entrepreneurship in India especially
someone like yourself who has work with
them because when it comes up to they
need money startup capital all this and
during these conversations what do you
foresee happen with the marketplace
[Music]
together and became a services
government is because the Indians are
basically of the period however Indians
still a developing country it's not a
rich country so people don't have cash
for becoming a manufacturing nation you
need capital either your own or that
which counts and gets invested here from
also Indian head like no because they
had like there there was no other way
for them to go ahead and give give play
to their entrepreneurial skills
unless devoted to the services sector
where actually the reach where capital
is much more okay that's one of the
reasons why we have done so burn the
second I think the important thing about
Indian and there is a there is a book by
one guru channeled us he writes
exceptionally well and if you can read
that book you should it says India grows
at night okay
so the fact of the matter is yeah the
fact of the matter is in here has always
good from the bottom it's not a
centrally controlled country the centre
has never been exceptionally useful okay
so the
the the entire enterpreneur spirit it
stems from the groceries and because of
that you know this country is very
different from many others that is one
of the reasons why even today if you go
to tier 2 tier 3 cities universities
you'll find small businesses you know
because people are doing something or
other and that's maybe one of the
reasons why even though we have 12 to 15
million people coming onto the work
stream every year in spite of that you
don't have the kind of social unrest
that you would expect you know any other
such country to have and that's one of
the reasons why I believe you know that
going forward this is a country that is
very very well suited to the new age and
the reason for that again is that really
well being it really possible I noticed
that we have changing Italy about
phosphorus those people who are
different yes so in India however it's
good to be disciplined I'm not saying
otherwise it's good to be disciplined
good to be root bound but you also need
that ability to be able to think you
know beyond the rules right act if
sudden suddenly SATs are surely things
happen you might continue to give this
example of the monetization monetization
happen in this country
86 percent of the moons of the current
events for suddenly consider environment
in this piece of one gauge 86 percent of
nodes in a country which is cash to the
extent of 12% of g-suits the cash
oriented economy and yet we managed of
course there were beings there bought
things but at the end of the day there
wasn't you know writing or looting or
anything of the sort and in 60 days time
the world system did manage to get back
on its feet and three monetization as we
call it happened so the fact is might
doubt very much whether it is such a
huge her exercise would have been done
in
hmm and you can imagine the logistics
requirement because you will the new
rules that will be printed they need to
be supplied then to be taken into the
far reaches of the country and can't you
currency boots in your pockets sure you
very move as it's called pressure you
have to have security you have to give
them the road plan you have to get the
clearances if you are moving it around
across state borders what the state
should be on board so you know there is
a lot of formalities towards the
logistics our fight mind blowing but all
of that still got done and we did it
without notice actually speaking very
few of people believed that there was no
notice but I am telling you God's own
truth notice one day's notice 8 o clock
in the evening we get to we are told we
are told next day's a holiday at the day
after we are up and running we have only
one day only one day in between we lose
bags for clothes and the next day at ten
o'clock we all opened our encounters and
we have you know history live maybe not
as many as we wanted but we have I
remember that yes so that's what I'm
trying to say that's where I think you
know the ability the of you know Indians
wins maybe it's some kind of a tensile
strength that we have I think that is
something that's very important to
understand that you know this is a
country that will sort of finder's fee
no matter what do a little more
hand-holding and make a path through
that so much of it
so you think some of these guys that are
all about following the rules and the
disciplines you think the younger
generation are the ones that are going
to break some rules and create new
innovation is that what you're saying
yes god again it doesn't do if you have
a society that doesn't look at this
appeal or it doesn't do but what I'm
trying to say is that you have to have
the ability to switch from one to the
other
given the crisis with your views about
the situation matrices in the normal
situation great to be absolutely this
opinion move out but if the situation is
normal not normal how then do you this
are you still able to manage you know if
you're given a set of circumstances
which you never envisaged how do you get
around it how do you manage in spite of
it I think that's something that's very
important incredible I can talk to you
for a while but I wanted to keep our
commitment to the time that we had in
thank you so much for welcoming us to
your place I've really enjoyed the
conversations thank you